the eyes to the right 272  the nose to the left  246  thank you  the eyes to the right  272  the nose to the left  246. so the eyes have it the eyes have  it unlocked  yeah they're moving on to other business  now other part other amendments not the  really contentious one that they've just  voted on uh  272-246 am i right i make that 26  majority a big drop in the government's  majority uh suggests a pretty sizable  revolt 20 or 30 perhaps with  more abstentions well the government  survives this controversial policy  survives but yet another significant  rebellion on the tory back benches and  there will be more uh complaints about  the prime minister's handling of this  which was very much bounced on mps at  short notice  john thank you very much indeed